il est valable il a fait qu'il a eue
quoi il a trois ans j'ai dû beau
petit chou est un petit patient un peu
étrange il fait partie des nombreuses
peluches aux maladies imaginaires venus
accompagnés de leurs amis de jeunes
enfants de 5 ans ils ont pu profiter
d'une consultation gratuite
[Musique]
ils arrivent ils nous disent le nom de
leurs doudous leur âge leur taille etc
on prend les constantes on l'est pèse on
leur demande quelle maladie longs et
après du coup on va pouvoir les emmener
au bloc opératoire où ils vont pouvoir
pas s'habiller un peu comme les vrais
sur un chien puis on va alors leur
montrer d'esserent qu'on peut faire pour
sauver le doubs et puis pouvez aussi
aller à la radio après on les amène à la
pharmacie donc là on a fabriqué des
petits médicaments défaut pour que
puissent vraiment prendre conscience de
ce que c'est un médicament la salle du
vieux marché à jouy en josas a pris le
temps d'une journée la lure d'un hôpital
pour nounours une quinzaine d'élèves en
deuxième année de médecine à
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines organise ces cessions dans
plusieurs villes des yvelines chaque
année une façon pour les enfants de
découvrir le monde médical une autre
façon on va endormir doudou comme ça il
aura pas mal pendant qu'on va réparer
son bras d'accord si justement pour les
sensibiliser déjà au milieu médical pour
qu'ils aient moins peur pour que quant à
eux ils seront amenés à l'échelle
médecin il ait confiance que ce qu'en
général les enfants qui sont un petit
peu free et surtout par les blouses
blanches parce qu'ils connaissent pas
trop mais là le fait de les avoir vus en
amont avec leur doudou ça leur fera
moins perquisitions et à l'hôpital où je
même chez le médecin généraliste et pour
les étudiants de se former à communiquer
avec les plus petits mois déjà
j'aimerais de pédiatres ça nous apporte
déjà le fait de pouvoir avoir un premier
contact avec les enfants c'est vrai que
en stage on a moins de sage de pédiatrie
ou autre on va souvent l'adulte est pour
sa part bien d'avoir un peu une approche
et les enfants parce que c'est pas la
même chose ils comprennent pas pareil il
faut agir différemment et entre les
différents mots attribués aux peluches
par les enfants une thématique semble
revenir plus que les autres
il a commis dans plus
long cours on a un virus a et la vie des
gens tous un profil épidémique mais que
personne ne s'inquiète tout lé nounours
ont été soignés à la fin les enfants se
sont vus chacun attribuer un diplôme de
nounoursologues pour en témoigner un
suivi des patients se fera ensuite dans
leur classe avec leurs professeurs